bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video io sono fan i j
oggi siamo tornati dopo circa tre
settimane dalla dalla prima uscita del
primo episodio su anti chamber a grande
richiesta praticamente consiste nel
passare da una da uno stage tra
virgolette all'altro
risolvendo degli enigmi ma facendolo in
modo da diciamo mandarti in botta al
cervello perché nell'ultimo episodio
anti chamber io letteralmente sono
andato fuori di testa
quindi raga in poche parole oggi avevo
voglia di sballarmi di brutto allora ho
detto facciamo un secondo episodio di
anti chamber in poche parole vabbè
andiamo avanti eravamo rimasti non mi
ricordo neanche dov'eravamo rimasti
comunque si può tornare nelle zone basta
cliccare cos'è sta roba
oddio ap ok sta cosa non me la ricordavo
allora ragazzi voglio soltanto dire che
non mi ricordo dove siamo arrivati
ovviamente perché l'ultima volta che ci
ho giocato è stato tre settimane fa però
ok
ok perfetto dicevo se passiamo nelle
stesse zone dell ultima volta dovrei
ricordarmi così come si fanno almeno non
ci perdo tempo e mi avete consigliato
gran consiglio che praticamente questa
pistola l'ha visto la serve per prendere
i cubi tipo quelli lì se riesco ok e
riposizionarli tipo per saltarci sopra
per fare tipo una scala eccetera e mi
avete detto che si possono prendere
anche più cupi insieme io sta cosa non
la sapevo
ok ok perfetto dato che raga qui crolla
al pavimento come potete vedere se ci
passo lì è una trappola e devo riuscire
a saltare però dicevo con sta roba qui
con sicuri che ho preso voglio provare
ad andare da praticamente c'è un punto
che c'è un burrone e norme non puoi
passare che l'ultima volta non ci sono
riuscito che era questo voglio provare a
vedere se riesco con i cubi almeno ok ok
perfetto forse ce la faccia attenzione
che idea yacht a me è venuta ok perfetto
piano bene ragazzi già stiamo facendo
non è una pessima idea lo so però è
l'unica cosa che mi è venuta in mente
che è il piano ci siamo ci siamo ci
siamo ok ci siamo quasi raga dopo un'ora
ok devo riuscire no è troppo lontano
così merda devo farlo più vicino
madonna che ansia ok ragazzola ciò la
dice l'ansia veramente ok ok ok poi c'è
allora dato che quando passo qui dentro
mi si smaterializzano incubi faccio che
non prenda linea anche ok infatti sono
spariti e adesso non ho la più pallida
idea di dove debba andare però c'è un
cubo qui da mettere però non posso
metterlo perché sono spariti tutti cubi
fantastico e allora qualcuno mi spiega
che cazzo allora facciamo che torna
indietro a sto punto raga direi di
andare giù perché tanto non posso più
tornare indietro e non mi ricordo dove
dove si va di qua
di qua non c'erano dato nella scorsa
puntata mi pare ok zona no
mi sta prendendo per il culo allora
aspettato un secondo maledizione fammi
passare idiota fammi pasticceri
no c'è acqua si perda
ok haga dopo due ore di tentativi non ci
sono riuscito merda devono andare da
qualche altra parte a sto punto andiamo
di qua non
veramente sono stato un ora e mezza ho
tagliato di brutto perché diciamo che
veniva fuori in europa lunghissimo dove
cazzo siamo bene non c'era prima
oddio ma che cazzo succede piano allora
sono arrivato di lì c'è una botola che
comparsa all'improvviso torno indietro e
si materializza una scala invisibile
perfetto non ho capito nulla di quello
che è successo allora va bene ciò che
sembra fuori portata magari è più vicino
di quanto ti aspetti che bel consiglio
allora non so che cazzo voleva non ho
idea di che cosa voglia significare ma
devo passare di qua perché si allora mi
sono rotto le palle di sti cosi che si
ricreano sembra un parco giochi quella
stanza raga devo andarci però non posso
ok
qualcuno raga me lo spiega no perché non
farò un altro episodio di sta roba
questo è l'ultimo ve lo assicuro allora
per passare qui dentro
ovviamente non posso perché pieno di
visti cosi di raggi ics me l'avete detto
voi nei commenti bisogna camminare
perché sennò non si riesce se cammini sì
così non si agitano in poche parole e
quindi la porta rimane aperta ok però
voglio provare un secondo a fare così
per vedere se si apre da un'altra tipo
se si è aperta merda che ha il film
piano piano piano piano ok si sono
aperte tutte e due
lì sotto non so che cosa c'era ma non mi
interessa vado di qua ok c'è un non lo
sa mi se c'è un condotto sembra quello
della lavanderia
ok bruttissima idea ma lo devo fare
ragazzi vado per merda
ok benissimo story salento cosa c'è di
qua eh va beh noi entriamo cos'è sta
roba
un uomo che raccoglie una moneta e poi
viene quasi schiacciato da un incudine
artistico ok non c'è niente life e the
way of finance in the right direction
che cazzo di fino a fatto l'ascensore ok
adesso avete capito che cosa intendo per
gioco che manda in botta ma perché già
il mio cervello sta chiedendo pietà così
perché se no ma allora vogliamo
prenderci una pausa un attimo
adesso non è che mi giro e mi trovo
mirabilandia no ok almeno quello c'è
l'ha praticamente quella è la fine raga
solo che non ci possa arrivare perchè
ovviamente ci sono sti cosi che non so
neanche che cosa sono vabbè andiamo
avanti per passare il suo punto devo
camminare si perfetto e c'è un muro
merda asi questo me lo ricordavo anche
dell'ultima puntata
ok ragali me lo ricordo ci sono le varie
diciamo opere artistiche che non so che
cosa sono e vabbè qua a sinistra c'è
l'occhio di sauron che come devo
prometterli l'anello per farmi passare
infatti adesso vi farà passare
ok bene stessa cosa per l'ultima volta
anche qui mi avete detto che devo
camminare per andare avanti se sti cosi
si agitano si smaterializza al ponte
quindi devo camminare per non farli
agitare così posso passare grazie raga
non ce l'avrei mai fatta ma questo lo
sapete già perché
io per risolvere un enigma ci metto
secoli muoversi lentamente attraverso un
problema può aiutarti a trovare la
soluzione grazie ma se me lo dicevi
prima magari ci arrivavo nello scorso
episodio ma va bene
ap cose up cioè ok ok non so che cos'è
quella roba lì ma non posso entrare
ci sono vabbè tanto questa è una nuova
zona che prima non avevo visto sì così
penso che si ricreino come faceva a
saperlo non lo so vorrei riesco a
passarlo stesso qua però no no
maledizione ma guardate incredibile o
per un cazzo di cuba non riesco a
passare vabbè lasciamo stare
ok qua non voglio sapere come si fa
e qua c'è una porta che è quella a e
quella chiesa di prima
siamo a ok siamo arrivati oltre ragazzi
ricordatevi e dove non riuscivo a
passare e allora non me ne frega una
minchia di tornare indietro sinceramente
qua devo mettere qualcosa no non penso
ok raga quindi sono riuscito ad arrivare
alla parte e dall'altra parte e devo
passati quasi però la porta è chiusa ea
devo fare forza se così forse così no
ma che cazzo ok ok ok ok chiaro chiaro
chiaro
ok ci dovrei riuscire perfetto mi
servono incubi grazie non si spreca
nulla
ok the right answer may also be the most
abuse once le risposte giuste magari
possono essere le più ovvie bene grazie
della perla di saggezza ma non mi hai
capito una mazza ma noi andiamo avanti
lo stesso incubi sono andati a [ __ ]
bene stiamo andando penso in paradiso
stavolta ok ci sono altre due porte
oddio c'è un'altra porta gamma c'è
un'altra porta gun ci sono due
ok ok due mi sembrano un po esagerate
non capisco che cosa mi possa avere
un'altra porta ayane
però non ho la più pallida idea di come
arrivarci comunque allora qua ci sono
gli altri cubi
li prendiamo ok e non so cosa devo fare
per andare avanti allora dovrei mettere
credo lei si è però mi manca l'altra
metà se non posso allora proviamo ad
aprire prima questa mi mancano dei cubi
se no non ce la faccio
ok ok ok questa porta ce l'ho fatta ad
aprirla l'altra no
che succede non ha veramente mi prendono
i corpi quando succedono ste cose perché
c'è non me l'aspettavo ma cioè non me lo
aspetterei mai che si smaterializza mai
aspettato che si smaterializza se una
scala ma andiamo avanti
c'è un'altra mi sembra di girare dentro
la lemonsoda quando entro in psicosi ma
dettagli sonntag su we are only have
just enough to get by vista frase se
devo essere sincero non ci ho capito
proprio una mazza ma proviamo ad andare
avanti lo stesso c'è un muro ok il muro
è chiuso quindi di qua non posso passar
c è
andiamo di qua c'è un'altra porta
semiaperta
ci sono dei ok devo mettere anche qui
dei cubi che però non ho i cubi cioè
maraga se ci mettono la lemonsoda che
smaterializza i cubi non posso portarmi
dietro certo figlio mio
allora qualcuno mi dice che cosa cazzo
oddio no che figo
ok questa 9 questa era una genia ta che
culo
cioè io ho premuto il tasto destro c'è
per caso praticamente e o
smaterializzato il muro perfetto
ok allora adesso posso passare però
prima voglio vedere che cosa c'è di qua
problemi simili possono avere soluzioni
completamente diverse
non ho capito il senso ma penso che qui
devo farmi nasc io debba farmi una scala
per salire
va beh questa è abbastanza ovvio ok vai
perfetto buongiorno c'è qualcuno devo
andare bene per andare in una certa
strada
devi costruirti il tuo pavimento ma
questo si costruisce da solo come
pavimento cioè non c'è bisogno di rho
costruisca bene c'è c'è un muro vabbè
mia sto punto lo scavo
ok perfetto bene ce l'ha fatta non sarà
che cosa ho fatto ma non importa andiamo
avanti
c'è un altro ascensore va bene andiamo
finché non siamo nei videogiochi horror
degli ascensori mi fido
ok c'è un'altra strada mai ok c'è chi è
questo e quindi quindi che cazzo ma di
nuovo qui ma c'era già stato prima qua
ma se frecce che cosa c'è prima cerno
non c'erano prima
mi stanno indicando di andare di sotto è
simile a ok mi ero dimenticato che prima
si smaterializza va no ma chi è figo c'è
prima si si materializzava la scala
adesso si materializza al soffitto
ok qua c'è una intanto trovata un'altra
strada a caso è qui che cosa ci dovrebbe
essere non lo so dico milan da allora
facciamo così
lascio tutti i cubi qui perché mi
servono è al massimo li riprendo dopo
bene adesso passo di qua ok
che cos'è sto podio dove che adesso sia
if you are being attention newell
misseri fin gara un dio che cosa potrei
dimenticare allora c'è un puntatore c'è
un cubo
ok per un attimo ottenuto la morte che
cosa mi significa sta roba
io devo a spingerlo che figo
ok bene ok sto spingendo a massa robe
tipo una leva sia abbassato l'ascensore
di ok allora devo andare su intanto vedo
c'è di nuovo c'è di nuovo quell'affare
che non ha idea di cosa sia ma quello mi
fa veramente paura allora noi andiamo
via di qua
intanto ci sono stanze che non so come
farò raggiungere però ora è l'ultimo dei
miei problemi
e vabbè c'è l'ascensore che che si
abbassava bene quindi dovrei riuscire a
fermarlo così ok che poi raga un cubo
che peserà sì e no un grammo che tiene
un ascensore me lo dovete spiegare
comunque allora adesso devo provare a
darmi lo slancio sì lo vedo
inutile che mi indichi lo sapevo allora
vado ci provo vai se ok siamo arrivati
siamo arrivati calmi allora io qui c'ero
già stato però non c'ero già stato
cazzate
la porta si è aperta bene
dove devo andare what we've dan no
stavolta non li canto linkin park di
forme impec 4 candle next sto provando a
ok
devo mettere bene questo non era un
enigma tanto difficile finora qua però
mi serve perché sta allagando mi serve
un altro cubo che questo qui indietro
perfetto
ok sto cristo punto raga larga non so
perché attraversa lo stesso cos'è ce
l'ha ok vedo la porta che siamo sempre
più vicini
l'unico problema è che qui ci sono un po
di gubbio un po di porte che non so come
passare
eh no no malizia ok come cazzo ci esco
da qua a buffet ok ok ci siamo ragazzi
siamo quasi
ci siamo quasi
ebbene che cosa devo fare per
raggiungere sta minchia di pistola es
no no mi chiamerà dimenticato che con
esche tornavo indietro no ma non potete
farmi tornare indietro così se provassi
usare quella fare come ponte aspettate
un attimo
ok nostro soprattutto la faccia
vabbè raga non so come andare avanti sto
facendo il giro più e più volte ragano
non so raga veramente ed è troppo dice
non so cosa devo fare
perdonatemi ma è troppo difficile se
volete che cos'è sta roba sta roba non
avendo l'avevo vista deve arrivare fino
alla fine poi mi sblocca qualcosa
credo di sì ok
[Musica]
raga prova a seguirlo un secondo dato
che ci metteranno secolo e mezzo credo
per fare tutto il giro della stanza
direi che posso tagliare ci siamo dopo
due ore dopo 2 dove cazzo andato ma
siamo scherzo ma no no ci sono stato 2
fottute ore non è possibile nodi
michelis puntato niente basta ma non vi
azzardate a chiedermi di giocarci ancora
no vabbè dai allora ditemi se vi piace
lo continuo se no posso anche ferma mi
fa per me è indifferente tanto tempo
devo iniziare tutte le nuove serie va
bene parlerò più avanti tanto noi non ne
parlo adesso
e vabbè dai me l'avevate richiesto e ho
provato a rifarlo avete scelto voi di
farmelo di fare io non ho detto niente
comunque
vabbè dai direi che posso finire qui
l'episodio mi sembra quella fare di
inception
questo mi fa capire che siamo nel mondo
dei sogni o cosa
poche domande meglio finire qui 6 il
video vi è piaciuto una solito lasciato
un commento mi piace anche la pagina di
facebook che trovate come al solito
nella descrizione di ogni mio video
se non siete ancora iscritti iscrivetevi
noi ci vediamo in un prossimo video
belle ragazze